Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here.
Before we jump into this episode,
I'm going to do something I very rarely do and that is to make a direct ask with
Hatton hand,
my brand new book just came out today.
It is called tribe of mentors,
subtitle,
short life advice from the best in the world.
If you like the podcast,
you will love this book.
I reached out to 130 people who are the best at what they do in sports
investing,
business,
acting,
directing,
you name it.
We got it,
cryptocurrency done and it turned out better than I ever could have expected.
Many of my friends think of all my books.
It is the easiest to read,
the easiest to use,
so check it out.
Please take a look.
I put out so much free material.
The podcast is free.
The 700 plus blog posts are free.
Every once in awhile I put out something like this and it's not that expensive,
so please take a look.
Tribe of mentors.com and it does make a great holiday gift or gift for others.
There's something for everybody in here.
It is really a choose your own adventure guide,
a buffet of options for improving your life,
both in business and in the personal sphere.
So take a look.
I appreciate you taking a look.
Tribe of mentors.com or anywhere that books are sold
optimal at this altitude,
I can
start shaking [inaudible].
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike and the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers.
And he said,
I've been doing Peloton five days a week now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week.
And you know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on.
And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes.
And I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that along with the realtime leaderboard are the main reasons that this
caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say ma accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category.
So there's $100 off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or you just want to get a fantastic gift for
someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim a checkout to receive $100
off any accessories including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim,
this episode is brought to you by convert kit.
My go to email service provider.
I use them for everything.
If you've ever wondered how professional bloggers,
podcasters,
youtubers and so on can build a platform they control and get the word out about
their best content,
email is still the answer.
People think it's all social.
Social social,
but one algorithm change and oops,
bait and switch.
Now you only reach 10% of your audience.
That is why I've doubled and tripled down on email.
After reviewing many different email service providers,
I ended up selecting convert kit for email like five bullet Friday,
which goes out to about a million people now because convert kit delivers on
what matters most to me at least easy to use systems,
split testing and resending technology,
both very,
very important.
High rates of deliverability and hands on customer service.
So whether you run a business or simply have,
say a serious blog convert kit has integrations with more than 70 different
services just about anything you might need including hosting sites like
wordpress,
ecommerce platforms like Shopify,
lead capture technology like bounce exchange or sumo and many more.
They also offer a visual automation builder that makes it really easy to deliver
the right content to the right people in your audience just when they want it.
If you want a segment in different ways,
which a lot of people do,
convert kit offers,
plans that adjusted the size of your business,
so it's a good option whether you have a thousand people or 1 million on your
list,
and certainly I am planning on growing and growing and growing and I don't like
switching email service providers,
so I thought very carefully about this before I selected them.
So check it out.
Take a look@convertkit.com forward slash Tim that's convert Con v,
e r t k,
I t.com forward slash Tim and you can get your first month for free to kick the
tires,
test it out.
That way you can give it a shot.
Make sure that it works for you,
your business and all of that goodness.
If you're like me,
I hope you'll find that they get the job done.
That's certainly been my experience.
So check it out.
Again,
that's convert kit.com forward slash Tim for a free month of email services.
Why hello boys and girls,
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show or
perhaps you're listening to the brand new tribe of mentors podcasts,
which is currently as of this recording number five across all of iTunes and
apple podcasts.
This is a cross post episode so it appears in both places and I'll keep this
intro short.
This conversation you're going to hear is with Tim urban and we'll get into his
bio in the actual conversation.
It was recorded at Barnes and noble in Union Square,
New York City on the launch evening of the tribe of mentors book.
You can learn all about that@tribeofmentors.com we had a blast.
The audience was awesome.
Thank you to everyone who came out and we'll probably be doing some more live
experiments like this.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my very wide ranging conversation with the ever hilarious and
fascinating Tim urban
[inaudible].
How's everybody doing?
All right,
this is exciting.
Thank you all so much for coming and it's a real honor and privilege to have you
all here and we're going to do something a little bit different tonight rather
than do what is the norm and perhaps what I've done many times before.
Just get up and tell you all about this book that you already own.
I thought we'd do a bonus round with one of the guests,
one of the people who was interviewed for tribe of mentors.
So I'm going to welcome him to the stage and just a moment,
but I'll read the bio first while I wrestled with the audio and a,
here we go.
One of my,
one of my favorite people in New York City,
so I'm excited and we'll be asking questions I've not asked him before.
So this is a rare live edition of the Tim Ferriss show in some ways also.
Here we go.
Tim Urban,
he was Tim urban,
Twitter,
Facebook at wait,
but why wait,
but why.com Tim urban is the author of the blog.
Wait,
but why?
And has become one of the Internet's most popular writers.
Tim,
according to fast company as captured a level of reader engagement that even the
new media giants or that even the new media giants would be envious of today.
Wait,
but why receives more than 1.5 billion unique visitors per month among them?
Elon Musk and has more than 550,000 email subscribers.
Tim is getting a number of prominent readers as well,
like authors,
Sam Harris and Susan Cain,
Twitter cofounder,
Evan Williams,
Ted Curator,
Chris Ashington,
that's one of my buddies.
Hi Chris Anderson and a brain pickings.
Maria Popova.
Tim Series of posts.
After interviewing Elon Musk had been called by boxes.
David Roberts quote,
the meatiest most fascinating,
most satisfying posts I've read in ages and quote.
You can start with the first one.
Ilan Musk,
the world's radice to man 10 his ted talk inside the mind of a master
procrastinator has received more than now.
I checked it yesterday,
25 million combined views.
Please welcome to the stage,
the incredible,
the brilliance and handsome Tim urban
[inaudible]
like your birthday party.
And I'm like stepping in the middle and it's very uncomfortable.
Well,
you know,
I said what other Tim can I bring into the fold for those people who are maybe a
little older like I am,
this is the t to the improved version.
That's terminator reference.
All right,
so I figure we'll jump into it and what we're going to do is we'll have a
conversation which mostly involves me just asking him questions and then we'll
jump into this fishbowl and answer some of your questions and then after that we
will have the opportunity.
We might be here for awhile so I will not be offended if people are like peace.
I'm out.
I don't want to wait a,
but we will have a chance to say hello and people who want to have photographs
and so on.
We'll be able to do that.
Okay.
Let's just jump right into it.
All right.
We put why before we put wine,
you and I chatted a little bit about this.
I guess it feels like a couple of nights ago,
but maybe it was yesterday.
I can't remember.
It's been a big week.
You blood casually for six years or so on the side.
Could you tell us about
that blog?
What subjects that you cover?
What characterized what you did part time for six years?
It uh,
so it was called underneath the turban.
So that's a little thing that I came up with.
Um,
and the turban.
Yes.
Cause my name is Tim Urban.
I was 23.
I wasn't taking,
that guy was not a serious project
and it was very much a side project.
I um,
it was actually,
I think I can credit because credit,
the fact that it was a side project for why I was,
I'm actually able to kind of be productive because I didn't have this pressure
to do it.
I was like,
you know,
what's my voice?
Who am I as a writer?
I wasn't a writer.
I was just doing something else.
I was going to blog to procrastinate from all the other things that are supposed
to be doing,
which liberated me creatively.
Actually.
I was able to kind of,
you know,
do my own thing and you know,
kind of find my voice and be,
you know,
kind of a little bit,
courageous at times.
Um,
and I think,
um,
I think so.
So for someone like me is actually like,
it was like a trick myself into,
uh,
actually doing stuff that I normally probably would have.
Um,
you know,
been a little bit more belabored and trying to get it going.
But,
uh Huh.
Yeah.
What type of subjects was it?
Was it similar?
How was it most different and how is it most similar to wait,
but why?
Yeah,
so it was very much more like a,
a blog blog.
You know,
I'd write about my day,
I'd rant about,
you know,
going to a store and then they had a McDonald's there and then they,
I was like,
don't get the six piece nugget,
you know,
get the four.
And then I ordered the 10,
and then they actually have the end of the nights where they give me teen and
then I eat all 18.
And that,
it was like that kind of like a story about my day.
Uh,
very much like just the top of my head,
just typing,
publishing,
you know.
Um,
and,
uh,
it never,
it was,
it was a small little passionate following of like 700 people,
like six comments on a thing.
And that was that.
And it was,
um,
it was this side project,
but it was a way for me to actually write like 300 blog posts over a six year
span.
What were the,
were there any seeds from that experience that then informed,
wait,
but why and why did you create wait,
but why?
Yeah,
and where's the name come from?
so,
um,
I was able to kind of hone my voice through writing 300 blog posts.
I look back at the early ones and I,
I when sit like the tones I was using,
so it was like 300 blog posts.
We'll teach you what you liked,
you know,
the voice you'd like to write in.
Um,
and uh,
so that's one thing.
And then I also like towards the end,
Isis decided one night to try to draw something.
Um,
and I kind of said,
let me,
you know,
I was going to try to depict this concept of,
that was funny when someone,
you know,
it was like doppelganger day on Facebook and someone posts a doppelganger that's
way better looking than they are.
I always think that's kind of hilarious.
Um,
and I was like,
I'm going to draw this.
I figured it's kind of messy looking at then like a handsome stick figure with a
wave of hair.
And so I did that and it hit me that I'm like,
I,
I was like,
that would be better and drawing.
And I realized I liked that.
And so I discovered that there too.
So when I started,
wait,
but why a couple of other people also respond positively to that?
Or did he buried yeah,
they did.
It got great feedback.
And then I started just,
every post on the lady was like,
the last seven posts on the blog all had drawings.
It was like,
I discovered that at the very end.
So then it was time just,
you know,
starting a new project.
Why was it time to start a new project?
Why not continue writing about the chicken?
Mcnuggets
good.
No,
it's not,
I'm not trying to be a dick.
I'm,
no,
it's fair.
And I,
and I also write about chicken nuggets.
I'm sorry,
this family programming.
Not sure.
Sorry.
Uh,
no,
I,
um,
it was,
uh,
I,
it was time in my life in general to like turn all my attention,
not a third of my attention to one creative project.
It was always I'm doing something with my full time and then I'm doing these
like two creative projects on the side.
I'm going to be a pain in the ass.
I apologize.
But that's my nature.
Why was it time?
Like what realization of conversation or getting fired or whatever catalyzed the
decision?
You know,
it's time for me to put all my eggs in one basket.
Creatively.
It's this thing you do that makes me love your podcast.
It's stressful being the person just learning this for the first time.
Um,
but,
um,
you know,
so for me it was actually,
I spent the years from the age of 22 to 31,
like hating myself a little bit because I was burning to do something creative,
whether it was writing or music or something.
Uh,
and,
um,
and I always was doing them on the side.
You know,
I,
it was like that,
that kind of,
uh,
that kind of leap of faith in my own kind of ability to do something creative
full time took me nine years,
nine years that,
uh,
that I wasn't very happy.
And so I finally said,
you know,
I,
this is,
I have to do something full time.
Cause I always thought if I could just do something full time,
but all the energy from all of these things into one thing,
it would go,
it would go well.
So I decided,
you know,
um,
I,
I actually owned a business with my friend Andrew Finn,
and it was the fact that,
uh,
the business gotten to a decent enough spot that we were able to start something
new and kind of,
that's when I jumped on.
What was the business?
It's a test prep company cannot,
this is a great business.
So [inaudible] who's a very successful novelist also got his beginnings.
It's a good starter,
a good like starter business aside and Robinson as well.
So three people in this book.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I think the together now,
who knew?
Who knew I was onto like the starter business idea.
I was just procrastinating from my music career is actually all I was doing when
I started it because I was tutoring on the side.
And then of course,
you know,
the other side things ended up taking all my time,
which is what classic procrastinator would do.
Um,
but yeah,
just simple kind of,
you know,
you'd be the,
each session pays for itself.
You don't need overhead.
You at the beginning,
you don't need any full time employees.
And so we,
but we had built it up to the point where we had good foot fulltime employees,
uh,
good enough to run,
um,
run it kind of without both of us there.
Um,
and so it was time to start something and we'd done this a couple of years ago.
We started the podcast app back in 2011 with the theory that podcasts were just
going to get bigger.
And they did.
Unfortunately,
we didn't know how to build a good app.
You built a bad app,
build a bad app.
Um,
but we,
but now it was a couple of years later when it was time for something new and I
said,
I'm going to jump on this and say I need to do something creative.
Let me see if I can do it as also a business that like we can kind of own
together.
You can run our tutoring company.
I'm going to go and start something.
And you know,
I was,
it was between kind of like writing a musical,
which is a terrible business.
I wouldn't want to drag him into that or writing maybe a a content website
that's,
that can,
you know,
have platform media platform that can,
that can be a business.
So that's why,
that's where we send along that I knew those were things I could do creatively.
Well,
and so we settled on this and the of the premise was like,
what if I took instead of five hours a week,
try to blog 60 hours a week to write a blog,
what will happen?
Um,
and it took the things I knew that I had gotten good at on the other blog,
which was just kind of writing colloquially,
um,
and uh,
and drawing stick figures and started it from there.
What is the origin of the name?
Uh,
16 hours on go daddy searching for dotcoms.
Um,
and man is,
there's not much,
there is not much.
Uh,
but I knew I didn't,
I,
uh,
I wanted it to be something that wouldn't pigeonhole it into,
you know.
All right.
So I mean,
when you're just typing in random combinations of words,
or is there some itch that you had related to the expression and then you do
have a habit?
I was imagining,
oh,
it's because people would say something to you and you want to test the
assumptions or you wouldn't accept it at face value should go wait.
But why,
you know,
that was in my head how I explained it.
I wish it,
I wish it was that situation.
I checked 2000 things and go down 150 came out.
Uh,
my girlfriend knocked out 140 immediately.
It was like,
absolutely not.
That leaves me with 10 where I was kind of like,
okay,
these are all bad,
which is the least bad.
Which if the site's good,
it can seem kind of cool suddenly,
maybe,
but it starts off bad,
but then it's not that.
And there's some of the other ones were just extremely embarrassing.
So I'm just
dangle that hook in front of me.
Were there any that I can give some examples too,
if it makes you feel any better,
if both titles that are horrible.
Uh,
but were there any that you really liked that your girlfriend shot down?
You were like,
we can both do this embarrassing.
Can you actually just,
you
okay,
I'll kick it off.
Uh,
so there was four.
What ended up being the,
for our work week,
there was lifestyle hustling.
Glad I didn't use that.
There was drug dealing for fun and profit,
which was promptly vetoed by every retailer.
Thank God.
Uh,
there was a broad band and the white sand,
I mean it goes,
it goes on.
So sometimes you need life to save you from yourself.
Those are kind of good,
at least heard sensical.
Like they,
they have some kind of,
I understand two of those three at least.
All right,
I'll take two out of three.
That's partially because I'm giving you like the better of the worst,
but near return,
miniature king.com
I wasn't a deep,
you'd go daddy's spiral.
You know,
if you ever been on one of these weird,
it gets really weird.
So I'm there and I'm like,
I'm like into this idea of a king because I picture the playing card cane.
I'm like so a miniature king and I suddenly got obsessed with it.
I was like,
he has little legs and he's very angry.
He's very like cranky.
And it was like big adult people walking by him and he's on the ground.
He's like two feet tall.
And my girlfriend was like,
Jesus.
Absolutely.
But I got so addicted to the king concept that when I started,
wait,
but why I made the logo that's playing,
I was just thinking he's pissed off.
That's amazing.
You were like,
okay.
Kind of.
Yeah.
I still kind of think miniature king could have worked,
you know,
he's the mascot.
He's,
he's cranky and anyway,
I like it.
All right.
But since then I've all,
you know what you can do all this happens.
I'll do you still own the Nutria can.com uh,
I own miniature king.com and about like 15 others.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
there's a lot of Jesus' half bro was going to do,
I'm a site where I'm Jesus,
his half brother and how he's like,
but he's not like the divine one.
He's just like born from like Jesus,
his mom with like some guy and he's,
and he's a upset.
What could go wrong with that?
Yeah.
He's got all kinds of,
all kinds of psychological issues going on.
You know,
he's,
he's trying to figure out his career.
What,
what were,
if you look back,
I look back and I remember the first,
my first attempt at blogging and like the first 12 posts and I mean they're,
they've thankfully mostly been forgotten over time.
But what were your first,
you had,
you had more practice,
you'd already put in 300 reps.
What were the first posts like?
Do you remember any of the topics?
Yeah.
Well,
so my early blog,
I mean the topics where it was like,
they started with like three sentence thing.
So one of the,
I feel like the first three was,
you know,
the title was frankly,
and then it said like peeing in the shower is wrong.
I don't want to be right.
That was a blog post back in the day.
Flash forward six years now.
Wait.
But why?
I knew more and I,
and I,
I knew right away it was going to be like long and thorough cause that's,
I just,
you know,
it was at my own site and I had a,
I knew I could get into depth.
Um,
if I,
you know,
could just go longer.
And so first the beginning,
I was anonymous and I'm sure you dealt with this too,
at some point,
you know,
you have to get attention phase.
So I,
um,
anonymous,
the only platform marketing platform I have is my personal Facebook page.
Um,
and,
um,
I started with seven ways to be in sufferable on Facebook,
which sounds like a buzzfeed headline,
but it was like much more in depth.
Uh,
I'd like gotten to the deep dark psychology of why like,
you know,
like the why it's the wild west of social etiquette and why we're all like our
very embarrassing version of ourselves on it and what the different like
qualities of negative human qualities that come through on it.
So that was the very first one.
I actually went to Easter island for a month before I started.
Wait,
but why?
To just alone in the middle of nowhere,
right.
Blog posts and pick like my favorite one to put on first to just kind of like
figure out what,
and that was the winner.
Why did you pick Easter Island?
Um,
I like the fact that you could take like a 2000 mile yard stick and swinging
around the island and not hit any people.
Like that was cool to me.
It was just so isolated.
Plus like the statues and the whole thing.
Uh,
and I was kind of like,
ah,
I've always wanted to go.
I was either there or it was going to go to Lithuania in the winter and just
creep out some small village.
Yeah.
Well,
well you could tell me a small village to creep out some time and they were just
going to actually talk to someone and they're like,
you may actually like arise arouse suspicion if you're like,
it's like foreign or like working every day,
just writing blog posts and isolation and all the small Lithuanian village.
Yeah.
It sounds like a George Clooney spy movie,
but I do want to,
I do want to do that in the mid dead of winter.
Go to like a small cold village somewhere.
Anyway.
So how did the blog posts do that one?
Um,
it did well,
the very first one I chose.
Well.
Um,
it,
how did you choose it relative to the other ideas that you had?
Trying to do some combo of like something that I thought was like true enough to
me that represented like the kind of quality I wanted to do,
but also that we could go viral just beginning.
Uh,
how can we go viral because that's the way you is this 2013 summer of 2013 in
Santa.
All right.
Yeah.
So that post did really well.
It got 500,000 uniques a month.
That's it.
Yeah.
My whole last blog got 250,000 uniques in six years.
So this was like,
okay.
Longer like getting into more serious topics and insulting people.
Like you know,
it's onto something.
Plus,
you know,
I would,
I didn't know at the time was that 2013 was a pretty magical year to be
promoting content on Facebook.
Ah,
this was,
that Facebook has decided let's show everyone just how powerful we are.
And they started made,
this is why buzzfeed exploded.
Then upworthy,
you first heard of it in 2013 viral Nova,
these sites exploded because Facebook's algorithm basically said,
anyone posting content,
we're going to show it to half a million people.
I was the right place at the right time.
And so that was very helpful as well.
Uh,
you know,
yeah.
I just to to maybe underscore one thing because for instance,
when I started my first business,
it was the golden age of Google ad words.
I mean,
it was shooting fish in a barrel is so inexpensive.
And then when the four hour workweek launched,
it was at the same time at south by southwest when Twitter was effectively
publicly debuted.
I mean,
there were big screens displaying all of the tweets in the world going on,
which happened to be concentrated right in Austin,
Texas because it was so small.
And I would say that any time is the right time in some way,
right?
So these opportunities we're talking about,
there are these opportunities right now.
You just have to try to sniff them out or to shoot in the dark and hope that
you'll catch some tailwind.
But,
uh,
everybody has,
it seems with these stories,
some element of luck involved,
but you can improve the odds cause that's just well,
right?
There's like 10 waves,
you know,
uh,
throughout your time.
One of the waves as crusty when you're starting,
you don't know which one,
but something is cresting at the time.
It's the perfect time to start something for some reason always.
Right?
And in every story where you find a component of good timing,
there's usually a quite a bad time,
right?
Like podcast APP,
like you were paddling for the right way,
but we're just doing it years too early.
Yeah.
Uh,
all right.
So I want to bring another figure,
another character into this picture.
Whose Winston can you tell us about Winston please?
Winston's a close friend of mine,
I met him in 2005,
uh,
when he was three months old,
um,
like purchased him.
And um,
you've lived happily together ever since.
He was the size of a golf ball at the time.
Now he's the size of a football,
which is a huge upgrade for him.
Uh,
he's a tortoise.
Um,
but he's,
um,
he's very lovable.
He's a,
he's kind of my apartment screensaver.
Like I'm just sitting there.
And what would be just an,
you was still seen and there's this like moseying thing,
middle moseying dinosaur that Moses by and who doesn't want that you should all
own a tortoise.
It's weird that you,
most of you don't own a tortoise.
Why did you name Him Winston?
Because I thought he had a church.
He'll look to him
or it's more the Churchill has a tortoise late to him.
I'm sort of imagining the A,
and then I know that they're not the same,
but like the sea turtles in finding Nemos,
it's like,
yeah,
I could see that.
Maybe he has less charisma,
but otherwise,
yeah.
Uh,
when I look at some of your posts,
and I've had my,
my life very directly and profoundly impacted by,
by some of your writing,
particularly about time remaining with say parents or family.
But when I look at some of your very research heavy posts and it feels funny to
call them posts,
uh,
whether it's on Ai or other topics that confuse a lot of people.
I mean,
we're talking about for those of you who don't have any familiarity,
in some cases,
50,000 words,
70,000 words,
that's a book everybody,
how long has the four hour workweek?
Four hour work week?
Uh,
that's a solid.
Now it's deceptive to use page count,
but that's how I think it's about,
I want to say what,
420 pages,
430 pages.
And it's not gigantic Dr Seuss print.
So it's probably closer if I'm guessing taking a stab to the hundred thousand,
120,000 word mark.
Uh,
I seem to have sort of word inflation with the books,
right?
They're getting bigger.
But when you,
when you're tackling one of these posts,
what are some of the approaches or questions you ask that allow you to write
something better and different?
Because presumably many people are out there trying to learn about these various
topics and yet you put out these posts that are the size of books that ended up
going viral and you make complicated or seeming the complicated topics.
Very digestible.
So what is your approach to tackling a topic like AI?
Yeah.
Um,
so
it's pretty simple for me for first of all,
like I just,
just,
I do this kind of weird thing where I assume that my audience is,
I picture like a stadium full of meat.
So it's narcissistic fantasy,
you know,
but it's like,
it's just,
I'm just writing for,
I'm writing the exact post that I would be thrilled to get.
Right.
So I'm just,
that's my focus group right there.
It's right in my head.
And it's easy because like,
you know,
we're all kind of like special,
unique people except not really.
There's like 100,000 copies of each of you out there somewhere.
And the truth is like,
you know,
if I just write for me,
there's a lot of people that have my exact what your taste.
I just know that.
So I start there with kind of like,
Ooh,
who am I writing for that?
That makes it easy.
Uh,
and so something like Ai,
if there's a one through 10 scale of how much you know about something,
10 is world leading expert in on,
you know,
one has absolutely never heard of the term.
Um,
you know,
I started the two or three on most stuff.
Like most layman,
I'm a layman right at everything.
Um,
and so then I spend it just out of my curiosity is the driver.
I picked topics I'm excited to dig into and I'll spend however long it takes.
Sometimes it's one day,
sometimes it's three weeks,
sometimes it's three months,
but I'll take as long as I need to,
uh,
to learn enough to get me to maybe like a five or a six out of 10,
you know,
I'm not going to get a phd.
I'm not going to spend five years getting myself to an eight or a nine,
but I'm going to get myself to a six where I'm like,
I can answer basically any question a layman asks me,
I can do a Q and a with an audience on this topic for 10 hours and I'll have a
pretty good solid answer to everything.
Not that I know necessarily the truth of everything,
but I know when the experts don't know the truth and they're arguing,
I know what the experts say about basically everything,
so I get myself to that level and then I think about,
okay,
so exports have sometimes a hard time explaining because they haven't been into
two in decades sometimes and they have this jargon and they don't remember what
it's like to be a two out of 10 I was there three weeks ago.
I know exactly what my readers know about this and I know exactly what,
so I just looked at the road,
I went down to get myself to a six and I think about,
you know what?
How can I do that road way more efficiently?
If I could go do it again now,
how could I do it in a much more fun way?
You know,
and what's,
what's this fun story I can tell to bring readers from the tutors six.
And so that's my challenge then is to basically package the road.
I just went down for three weeks and make it an hour and a half a package
instead.
Okay.
Not Surprising.
Lamps and follow up questions.
Uh,
let's pick a subject.
Have you written about cryptocurrency or blockchain?
Not yet.
Oh,
perfect.
So highly requested,
Tom.
I'm sure it is.
Now the reason I ask is that much like a,
I,
I have seen dozens of people attempt to explain without misrepresenting
cryptocurrency and blockchain 101 for the masses.
And it seems like almost every single attempt has failed.
If you were to take that assignment on,
where would you start?
I would,
I always start,
I feel like I'm blindfolded in the room and I'm just trying to figure out where
or even the walls here,
you know,
where is the furniture?
I just want to start an understand what I even need to learn.
So I want to get a picture of the topic and then I can start diving in,
going on various rabbit holes and usually going outside of the topic or a rabbit
hole outside the topic is procrastination,
but it also often,
you know,
it gives you even more context.
Uh,
you'll find some metaphor out there that you ended up bringing back.
So I'll just read and read and watch youtube videos,
uh,
all on the Internet.
How do you search?
So I'm reading,
are we talking,
you started Wikipedia is at ground zero.
Yeah,
I'll start a Wikipedia all,
uh,
for just a basic foundation.
What can be as good at telling you where the walls are.
Just letting even understand the topic in general and we can beat,
he has a lot of good,
good knowledge on it.
So I'll go there.
Then I'll go to the bottom Wikipedia and start clicking on all the reference
links.
Um,
and I'll usually Google like,
you know,
blockchain pdf and you end up finding all these superbly boring,
journal articles.
Um,
and then I'll go on youtube.
There's a lot of good people,
smart teachers explaining stuff on Youtube.
They're not going to explain the whole thing.
Usually they're going to explain one part,
maybe I realized that to understand blockchain,
you need to first go down three layers.
You need to build a foundation that begins with understanding what encryption
is.
You need to understand how encryption works in public keys and private keys.
That's when you can start to on top of that,
build an understanding of what a ledger is that would be on these different
computers and how it could possibly be secure.
And by the time you get to blockchain,
you're like eight layers up.
But,
um,
so I'll go find a youtube video,
not on blockchain but on encryption.
And then I'll find a youtube video explaining what ledgers are in general.
I wasn't reading about the history of ledgers and where they're used in the
world and you know,
encryption and where it was in,
you know,
how was invented and how it's evolved and you just keep doing.
And the reason I,
it's easy for me,
this part is because I'm super curious.
So the more,
the more I learn,
the less icky the topic gets.
When the topic gets uneasy,
it gets started to be super delicious,
the opposite.
Um,
and then I,
and then I kept meet another that starts with it's so fun.
Suddenly I'm like,
I get it.
And then I just want to like fill in the knowledge and I want to watch a youtube
video I already know the answer to just to feel good about,
oh man,
I already knew everything that he's saying.
This is great,
but it solidifies it.
You hear seven different people articulate it in seven ways and you just rounds
out your understanding and um,
and by the end they start to be like,
I totally get this finding.
I find a video on youtube.
So last I checked,
which was not recently a youtube is the second largest search engine in the
world.
It's a lot of great stuff.
There's also a lot of nonsense.
How do you search?
So what are the terms?
How do you sort them?
How do you go about kicking properly?
Well,
so in Google it's,
I just,
I will Google like blockchain,
leave that in a,
in a window,
open a new window and I'll Google,
um,
uh,
bitcoin new window theory of new window,
cryptocurrency,
new window,
like decentralized systems,
crypto new window,
like the cryptocurrency is bullshit new window.
Like,
um,
you know,
whatever.
And I'll just keep going and I'll just think of anything.
And then each one of those windows I go back to and I just hold down command and
I just click,
click,
click and I 10 tab 10 tab 10 times.
And I just go and read everything.
So that's Google,
you know,
again,
beyond that,
I don't have to discern,
I don't care if this Gizmodo article is going to be really useful,
you know,
whether it's going to be accurate because it's the beginning process is just if
you read 70 articles that may or may not have validity to them,
uh,
the total,
some of them actually start to understand what do we know as a species?
Where are we all agreeing?
And then where clearly a lot of people don't know what they're talking about.
Or there's this broad,
you know,
there's this kind of dichotomy of a view in this one area is,
is these people.
And then as these people,
Youtube is kind of the same thing.
I'll just start watching without discerning.
Again,
if you're a procrastinator,
it's fantastic because you don't feel bad about just watching endlessly when
you're taking all of your time and it's not what you're supposed to do.
And it feels great.
So,
um,
I'll just,
I'll just watch.
And then of course the sidebar starts to figure out you to very quickly and
Google will figure out what you're doing and then youtube will start to put all
of the things on the side for me.
Plus you start to see names you trust to make money in cryptocurrency.
Yeah,
well even just,
it's funny,
I've just writing a post now on like won't get into this,
but like,
you know,
political stuff and you know,
normally my sidebars like,
look how much of an idiot Trump is and his voters.
And then I go to the,
I'm now trying to tell,
you know,
I was googling all of these conservative things and because I'm writing about,
both sides of stuff,
and suddenly the Internet starts to indoctrinate me the other way and they're
like,
look at this.
Like,
why is Trump voter like,
embarrass this?
Like,
and I,
and I look over and I'm kind of like,
no,
like,
and a couple hours later I'm like,
Trump's the best.
Like,
you know,
let's go.
So like the Youtube figures out your angle and it will start to kind of like
feed your stuff.
Um,
and then there's certain names you trust,
you know,
Hank and John Green,
like I trust them,
you know,
[inaudible] get sod.
I trust them.
Um,
CGP grey as trust him.
So certain,
you know,
you'll see certain names you trust minute physics.
Great.
So,
um,
there's also that,
and it's same with thing with them.
You know,
Google,
of course,
like I'll trust
sources more than others.
And once you've ingested massive amounts of information and you've established a
basic map for the territory,
what do you think?
Are the tools or approaches,
anything at all that that help you to be so good at teaching these subjects in
the way that you presented or structure your pieces?
Yeah.
Well,
so again,
the starting point is I'm like,
I just went through this and I had to teach myself and I was bad at teaching
myself because I didn't know what I was doing.
So now if I could,
I,
the experience of a learner is fresh in my head.
So that's the first thing.
It's helpful.
Um,
but then I always,
basically with almost any explainer posts like that,
I just zoom out helicopter up.
Like,
you know,
if you're,
if you're looking at,
um,
the land and you see kind of like a,
a beach,
you don't know what it is.
Is it,
is,
is that,
oh,
is this a huge lake?
Uh,
is this a,
is this a little beach?
And then there's,
there's a curve around,
I don't know.
That's how I feel like a lot of the articles on AI or crypto currency are,
they show you a piece of beach and they,
and,
and then the odds are,
might have a full understanding,
but you just look at your,
they're just,
they're just describing the beach.
And so you take a helicopter up and you're like,
oh,
okay,
wait a second,
this is a big river.
And there's a there and you go take up further.
And you're like,
oh no,
this is uh,
this is kind of a tributary that goes into the ocean.
And,
and now you're kind of up where airplanes go.
And maybe even the international space station goes and you're like,
ah,
okay,
this is actually what's going on.
So I start there myself as a thinker and then when I'm trying to explain,
I'm just going to start that were just why,
you know,
people make fun of me and he's like,
I'll write about three different things.
And they all started the big bang by the time I'm like,
dumb it down.
I have to base on you.
Go back to the now.
Um,
but like sometimes like it's helpful to you just like you just,
um,
by the time you get from the big bang to now suddenly it's like we're all like
we can see the whole coastline of now the beach suddenly makes sense.
And then I tried to make it fun also because who wants to like Sony,
you know,
like the journal articles for the experts.
Like they're often just,
they don't because they're not reading to entertain,
you know,
and they're just an,
it's just bad.
It's like textbooks in school were so bad.
There were so boring.
Part of the reason I like youtube is because the people who end up with a lot of
views on youtube that are going to end up,
you know,
on,
on my recommended recommended thing there.
They have an eye for entertainment.
So I tried to do the same.
Well and if you were to ask say friends of yours,
who are fans of your writing,
what your ingredients for entertaining are,
what might they say or just to ask you?
I'm just not sure.
I don't want you to do,
I don't want you to be overly self deprecating.
I'm struggling.
Um,
yeah.
What,
what,
what makes it entertaining?
Because it is clearly,
well,
I again,
entertaining means 10 different things to 10 different people.
I get,
you know,
every time I get nine emails from like,
mothers and Kansas angry at me for swearing,
but like,
you know,
it's,
it depends on,
you know,
it's,
um,
I think trying to ad sense of humor into basically everything.
You keep treating it light.
Um,
good metaphors.
Uh,
you know,
and that for me,
lots of visuals.
I'm a visual learner.
If I see a block of text and I'm just scrolling down,
I'm kind of upset.
It's like,
feels like homework.
But if I can scroll down and every few paragraphs,
there's a chart,
there's a comic,
I'm suddenly like,
okay,
this is fun.
I'm,
I'm kind of excited.
Like,
and so that's how I think.
So I tried to do that.
That's what I would want.
So I like,
I like,
um,
you know,
like there's so many things where you can just do a funny stick drawing or a
really good diagram and just it just way clearer and sticks in your head more.
You know,
if I'm going to talk about procrastination,
I could talk about like the,
the,
the limbic system and you know,
talk about,
um,
you know,
how it works and it's our fight or flight zone.
Or I can make an instinct gratification monkey and like,
cause that is essentially what it is and that's more memorable and I think more
fun to read
at the time.
So you've really,
in my opinion,
uh,
exhibited a mastery for taking what many people would consider extremely
intimidating subjects,
uh,
many of them involved in the forging.
What we're going to experience as a species is the future.
So I'd like to talk about the future for a second,
and I want to read a quote here.
All right.
Believe that you wrote or said this.
So correct me if I'm wrong.
I always thought the future would be intense,
but now I think the future is going fully fucking crazy.
Okay.
So what are a few things that you're excited about or see coming down the pike
in the future?
It doesn't have to be one or two babies could be many.
It is going to be crazy.
And here's why.
So the first thought a lot of people have,
um,
is that it's naive to think that the future is good.
This is all weird.
The end of times everyone thinks that you know,
you know,
you're just another night.
You've person that thinks they live in a special time because,
and the reason we all have that instinct is because we are biology moves very
slowly.
It evolves very,
very slowly.
So 50,000 years is nothing in biology and evolution.
So we barely changed meaning we are still a baby.
Born today is a baby that is perfectly optimized to live in a tribe in Ethiopia
and 50,000 BC.
And it is everything about it is ready for survival in that world.
But what we've done is taken that baby away from its home planet and brought it
to another planet,
which is the earth in 2017 and that baby isn't made very well for this world.
None of us are.
Okay.
So,
so the,
the first thing to think about is just that a lot of our instincts and a lot of
our,
you know,
intuitions are actually going to be inherently wrong.
We're going to be living in a delusion that was helpful back then today just as
is not great.
So the reason,
the way you can cut through this and actually see reality when you're the bait,
that baby is not,
it's not seeing reality isn't helpful to that baby fitting in with the tribe is
and bleeding with the tribe believes it.
So today we want to see reality.
And so you can do things like,
you can just look at the facts sometimes.
So managing the,
the,
it's gonna be a long answer.
Um,
I imagine that,
I have a lot to say about us.
I imagine that this is what I want to say saying,
but the zoom out,
this is a,
it's a thing enters or can't be short in my head.
So,
um,
and that in the human history is about a thousand central comfortable folks get
settle in,
um,
a thousand centuries of human history.
A hundred thousand years.
Okay?
So each two centuries is a page in a book,
okay.
How many pages does this,
that's 700 8,500 pages,
let's say.
Actually,
you know,
whatever ain't gon make me mad that they're finding older human roommates.
So fine.
So 140,000 years,
every page in this book that you're holding is 200 years in human history.
Okay?
Um,
so page one through six 50 of that book,
Hunter Gatherers,
if you're an alien reading this book to understand what happened on this planet,
your board,
I mean,
it is really boring.
Page six,
50,
10,000 years ago,
you have the agriculture revolution,
okay,
wait,
so suddenly people are coming together,
forming cities,
okay?
They're starting to actually form larger civilizations.
They have a collective intelligence,
uh,
that starting to form.
They can compare notes.
They can kind of create a knowledge tower that is bigger than any one of them.
It's very interesting stuff.
So that's 50 pages ago.
Then it gets boring again for awhile.
Okay.
Page six,
90 out of 700,
right?
It's a little tiny end of the book.
Here you have Jesus,
you have,
you know,
six 93.
You have,
uh,
the advent of Islam.
The Roman empire happens two pages ago.
It's already done.
Um,
697.
You have imperialism for the first time.
You have countries.
This is new thing that happened in the last three pages.
Page six 98.
Um,
you have the enlightenment,
you have the renaissance,
you're things like this.
It discovered that there's galaxies,
telescope page 699.
You have a,
you,
you finally get to the beginning of the u s and the beginning of kind of
constitutional democracies.
Right now.
Page 700 happens,
which is from about 200 years ago till today.
Okay?
So the beginning of page 700,
the alien turns the page.
Industrial Revolution happens.
Okay?
Big Deal.
Big Change.
Okay.
And as reads on the page,
things start to go crazy.
You start to have you,
you,
you have an 699 pages.
This alien or thread,
this boring ass species has,
has communicated through letters and talking.
Uh,
you know,
he was excited about language 500 pages ago.
Now he's born,
um,
smoke signals firing a cannon ball in the air and stuff like that.
Okay?
Suddenly on page 700,
we'd go to the space station.
I mean in the space station we have the moon,
we have airplanes.
You have card just on page 700,
699 pages,
okay.
We have a,
and B,
we only communicate through,
well,
we have these kind of,
you know,
simple,
uh,
transportation,
communication.
Now we have,
we have face time,
okay?
We have,
you know,
we,
we have,
we have telephone,
we have the internet.
I mean crazy,
right?
Less than a billion people.
But the first 699 pages on page 700 alone,
we crossed the one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six and 7000000001st and marks.
So the aliens reading and like,
cause his wife comes in and is like,
hey,
we're going,
we're going to have dinner.
So most intro,
riveting things on things like what is about to happen to this species.
This is,
this is crazy.
We just happened on this page here.
This is when we're born.
We're born at the end of page 700.
Okay.
So
[inaudible]
what do you think the future's going to be like?
I'm like,
Oh,
page seven oh one and they're like,
how's this guy?
There's no way.
It's the shit just goes bonkers.
Yeah.
The three sentences on page seven,
no one will take us to 2025 when they predict it.
Like,
you know,
AI is going to basically infiltrate every single industry and part of our lives
the way electricity did it,
like a 10 year span of 1880s I mean that's the first three sentences.
So to me,
I see revolutions,
the onset of the pages of the first half of page seven oh one the first quarter
of page seven Oh one I see revolutions and uh,
you know,
Vr,
Ar,
I see revolutions in Ai.
And see revolutions in brain machine interfaces.
We're going to be able to think thoughts to each other way cooler than language
for the first time.
Um,
were icy revolutions in genetic stuff.
Your grandkids are going to be like so cheap.
You just had a baby and hoped it was a good baby.
It's going to seem crazy to see so permanent.
Um,
and you can just go on and on and on with things that you're,
look,
how about this one?
Okay.
What are the major leaks for life?
You can count on one hand for all of life.
Simple cell to complex sell big one complex cell to multicell big one.
We have animals now ocean to land.
Big One.
I would say the fourth that fits on this same list is going from one planet to
multi planets as a civilization that's happening in the next decade with his
space.
No one talking about it yet,
but they will be,
I mean,
just the fact that like we're going to witness in our lifetimes one of the great
leaps for all of life.
Like this isn't normal.
So yeah.
Okay.
So I want to talk about extra planetary.
Um,
just a couple of,
of,
uh,
curious notions that I've been bouncing around in my own head.
If you had to bet on more humans inhabiting,
say,
Mars or inhabiting space stations that don't have to conquer a separate gravity,
where would you bet?
Because there are competing camps or at least technologists who are looking at
say,
habitating other planets or saying,
no,
that makes no sense because now you're dealing with a separate environment,
gravitational fields,
et cetera.
We're going to just build space stations.
Yeah,
I'll take bars for awhile.
Uh,
Mars is probably going to have a million,
you know,
in the next five or six decades and then it'll eventually probably end up in a
billion people.
But,
uh,
I think space stations in the long run way better.
I mean,
it's gonna seem really crappy to be on a planet.
Uh,
it's going to be,
you know,
being on a plan.
It's going to seem very old school and very kind of rough compared to the space
station.
We can,
you know,
imagine dealing with whether it's going to seem crazy that you'd have to deal
with weather that you had to deal with.
Things like climate change.
It's just not,
not our problem.
We have to deal with bugs.
It's my,
I be so happy there's no bugs on the space station.
So,
um,
so I think in the long run that,
but I have a more important question,
which is are you going to go to Mars?
No,
no.
Well,
not in the near term.
I don't to be the first monkey shot at the first Mars.
I'll led quite a few people work out the kinks on that one.
I mean,
we can't even figure out how to upgrade ios without replacing I
fucking images.
Like I'm going to let someone shoot me to Mars.
No,
no,
not early.
No.
Okay.
Now picture is 20 years from now and the last,
you know,
every 26 months,
earth lap smarts.
Okay.
And they ended up next to each other and that's when you have this window to go.
So every 26 months there's going to be a fleet to colonial fleet.
Heading there and another fleet coming back,
bringing people back,
round trip tickets.
Um,
different people on the legs,
right?
Yeah,
no,
exactly.
And just,
I'd be like first class things,
it'll be like fancy people,
but everyone be like jumping around,
bouncing around with the gravity.
It sounds great.
Like zero gravity cruise ship.
So question is for you.
Uh,
it's 20,
38,
2020,
45 and it's a,
it's been proven for the last like 20 trip back where no one's gotten hurt.
It's totally safe.
Would I visit?
Yeah.
What's the total time invested at this point in the trend?
Let's say the first,
the shortest round trip you can do as a 52 month or
I would,
I would strongly consider it.
Okay.
I heard,
I heard Jeff Bezos recently on stage,
you know,
before you think about going to Mars,
spend a month in Antarctica,
that's a cakewalk.
Oh,
Antarctica is way better than Mars,
Antarctica,
but 15 or 20 degrees colder,
you can't breathe the air.
Uh,
uh,
you can't be outside in the sun without a radiation suit.
Uh,
I think it depends a lot on the brochure of Mars Club Med that I received.
Yes,
it's not
a,
all right.
Shifting gears a little bit.
Ai,
do you think it is an existential threat or not?
And if so,
what is the time horizon for becoming a,
a imminent existential threat?
Um,
so this is the,
one of the great questions.
Uh,
you know,
AI is probably the subject I've talked to most experts on,
so I'm not an expert,
but I've really know what the experts think.
And I tried to keep up to date because they changed their minds a lot.
Uh,
so it will be fine.
No,
we're all done.
we'll be fine then.
We're all done.
What I find is very few people who don't think this is going to basically take
over everything.
Uh,
the question is when,
and I was surprised that even the people that are pessimistic,
they kind of think,
oh,
it might be a hundred years from now on.
Most people think 50 30 and people at deep mind these days at Google,
which is like the leading Ai Company.
Now they're saying things like 10 and this is what I say 10 10 till what I'm
talking about.
Um,
you know,
before any of this moment happens,
it's like there's to understand Ai,
you have to think about two things.
There's narrow intelligence and there's general intelligence.
So humans have general intelligence.
We are smart across the board.
Okay,
we have,
we have social skills,
we have creativity,
we can understand math,
we can read,
we can be creative,
we can learn from experience.
You just name it,
name anything.
Humans can kind of learn how to be smart.
They're okay.
But when you think about Ai,
AI is way better than any human at the things that's good at like chess is that
the world chess master,
right?
Of course.
And it's the,
it's the real master at everything that it does well,
but it's only good at that one thing for this AI on your phone.
Does AI in your car and this AI running most stuff at this point,
but it's only good at one thing.
So the question is,
when will AI become,
gain?
That same breadth that we have when we'll have become broadly smart.
And until then,
it's still going to change the world.
It's still going to take a huge amount of jobs and,
and,
and create a whole new,
you know,
a whole bunch more.
Um,
so it's going to be a massive group of changes that happen even before we get
general intelligence.
But the question that I was referring to before is when do we get to this level
where AI is now smart like we are,
but way,
way smarter.
What Nick Bostrom called Super Intelligence where it's,
it's a smarter than us as we are then monkeys.
Yeah.
So basically if you picture like not only can a monkey not like build this room
are not only can,
you know,
when you look out in the night sky and you see little lights moving around,
humans are so smart.
We put those there.
We put airplanes in satellites in the night sky,
right?
So not only can a monkey not do that,
um,
you can show the monkey the light.
So this building and you can't,
you can't even understand that you did.
It just will think that it's just there that's just as moving star,
right?
So we're talking about something that not only can we not do what this thing can
do,
we can't even understand that it did it,
even if it tried to explain it.
That's how smart this thing is to really crazy concept.
So things that we think are hard like curing disease,
poverty,
you know,
climate change,
name it,
you know,
anything that we consider a challenge,
uh,
easy piece of cake for the AI.
So that's the really exciting side.
And then there's the,
what if we're not in control of it the way we want to be,
not that it's going to be evil.
That's this anthropomorphization that people do.
They try to apply human stuff to this thing that's not human.
But when you build a house and there's an ant hill there,
you're not like ha depth to the hands.
You just build a house and they were in the way so you killed them.
Big Deal,
right?
The fear is that the ad is doing its thing.
And that it just,
we're kind of in the way and that we programmed it in a way that we didn't think
of this thing,
but now it's too powerful.
We can't change it and,
and we're toast or it gets,
it gets annoyed that we're doing something to it that it doesn't and we're
toast.
So you have some high stakes here.
Uh,
and which is why basically we're going to have God on earth because we can play
God to every other animal right now.
Even a chip chips are really smart until we put it in a cage.
Now when are you going to do,
we haven't gotten,
we have a taser.
We can poison it's food.
Chimps are nothing compared to our God like ability because we have a little
intelligence gap over them.
Little in the scheme of things,
when this thing has a big intelligence gap over us,
it's truly complaint God to us.
So the question is,
is it a good God that could solve all of our problems or is it like one of those
Dick Gods in the Old Testament?
Like that guy.
So this is what the,
this is what they're talking about.
This is why AI safety so important,
but most of the money in time is going into AI development right now.
So the last question then we'll go to go to audience questions.
Uh,
how do you view happiness?
Just to bring it back to things that we may be able to influence,
at least speaking for myself and a lot of people in this room.
Uh,
how do you view or define happiness for yourself if you do it all?
Yeah,
well I kind of think of,
um,
there's two kinds of happiness that you have to kind of deal with.
Both.
One is like micro happiness,
like are your Tuesday's good that you generally having a good Tuesday?
Uh,
and then there's like macro happiness.
Like are you present?
Are you like,
yeah,
I'll dig into this current life for 20 years.
I love it.
Or are you like,
I was for nine years after college,
which is like,
well,
I'm doing this now,
but I really want to like I should be doing,
you know,
and that's macro happiness.
So I think you have to worry about both.
I think that the most important one to get right at the beginning,
at least as a macro,
I think if your macro happiness isn't there,
you know you're gonna,
you're going to have,
um,
you're gonna,
you're going to feel frustrated,
kind of,
you don't have a cloud over you.
And then I think you can work on micro happiness,
which is about lifestyle.
This is what you're so good at and is,
I think a lot of people here,
you know,
really both for both kind of happiness as they look to you because you have a
lot of good advice.
But I think with Mike Rowe,
you really have,
you focus so hard on like just really crushing like a Tuesday.
And I think like that,
but all life is,
is literally a Tuesday again and again and then you die.
So the crushing the Tuesday's the title of my next book,
let's get good at it.
Right?
White Sand in Tuesdays.
Um,
but so yeah,
and,
and the,
the,
with the,
with the hard thing that's hard is a lot of times we as so be assumed that it's
the external world.
We have to succeed.
We have to,
you know,
get,
get this relationship and then we'll be,
and you know,
this is kind of Cliche,
but we know that it's,
it's,
it's the,
it's messing with your internal expectations.
It's getting your mind in the right place and,
and,
and kind of seeing reality and get,
see what is your ego and what is your fear and what is kind of,
you know,
worrying about judgment and what is actually real that matters to you.
And,
and realizing that a lot of the perceived risk isn't really dangerous and a lot
of their perceived reward isn't really gratifying.
And this,
it's all there in front of you.
If you can just look past your primate self with your very rational intelligence
self and just see it and then learn to internalize it,
often suddenly the happiness is or you know,
become very clear how to work themselves out.
And it's up and often we end up spending all our time trying to get to those
happinesses with the primate kind of self in charge.
And that usually doesn't get us there.
So the add to that reality minus expectations,
is that a useful framework for defining happiness,
do you think?
Yeah,
I mean if,
so you're just saying you know what your happiness is like an equation.
Reality minus expectations is your happiness and um,
and so you can work on two things.
You can work on improving your reality or you can work on not lowering,
but kind of like refining your expectations to reflect what actually matters to
you,
which will almost always end up with them lowering in a certain sense.
And maybe maybe going up in another sense,
but um,
you know,
the classic trap of course is like,
you're in a way better place than you were 10 years ago,
but you're just as unhappy because you're the hedonic treadmill concept is this
term that psychologists use that you know,
you just,
your happiness goes up because something really good happens.
Even like,
you know,
the little examples,
you get a new,
you buy something new in your wake up in the morning,
you're like,
oh my iPhone x 10 whatever.
And you're like all happy.
And then like,
you know,
every day that that goes down in six days later,
it's just you're stupid iPhone again.
But we use this in a macro sense.
You get the new job,
you finally get into a really good relationship,
you work it out or you know,
you have a sick friend or a parent and then they get healthy and wow.
And then,
um,
instead of just,
you know,
so the obvious way to,
um,
to,
to get off the treadmill is,
it's obvious just sets over,
grabbing gratitude.
There's like what I have,
what I want.
And like looking up,
you're going to be really unhappy and if you keep the mountain keeps growing
underneath you,
but you're not even looking at it,
you're just looking up all the time.
It's going to seem like everything sucks.
If you're looking down,
you're like,
look at this mountain,
it's amazing.
Look at all the things I have.
Like you're going to be really happy.
So like the,
the gratitude things are real,
like all the,
you know,
the thing we is just to write three good things that happened that day.
Uh,
every night before you go to bed,
write three good things that happened and why they happen.
The reason that people want you to,
that psychologist say this is good is because it trains your brain to all day be
thinking,
wait,
what's good and they have to do this thing tonight.
Like it's just what's good,
what's good,
and you're suddenly you're looking down and all of these things that are good in
your life as opposed to kind of looking up at what sucks,
what sucks about the situation,
how has the world wronging me,
which is a
pure recipe for unhappiness.
Okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to try to put a little icing on top just to,
just to add to that,
which is as reading recently about some of the supposedly objectively assessed
happiest places on earth.
And if you look at them,
three of them are Costa Rica.
Ego,
Buddha.
Okay.
Screwed up my gender already.
It's not bad to do and these days,
Huh?
All right.
At least I did it in Spanish.
Uh,
so moving on,
I'm going to move,
move on quickly.
Costa Rica,
Singapore and I sing porn.
Is everyone a shout?
Okay.
Uh,
I'm all for it.
You don't see it as much in Singapore and then Denmark.
All right.
So,
well you can,
you can write a letter.
I love Norway,
but I will,
I will,
I will rely on national
geographic.
You can write them an angry letter.
Uh,
they are very communicative.
That's fine.
So Norway,
awesome.
But I can only speak,
I can only speak
to the dance,
but I will give you the official gold medal.
But the silver medal for the dance.
And I want to point out a couple of things.
Knowing people in all three places that in Singapore there's very much an
optimization for improving your reality.
It's very achievement focused and there's a large economic component.
Nonetheless.
The various combination of factors lead them to be in the very top.
On the perhaps opposite side of that equation,
or at least in the alternate side,
you have the Danes.
And I know a lot of Danes and I remember one point without even bringing up any
of this,
I said,
you guys are apparently really happy.
Why do you think that is as a group?
They said we have really low expectations.
I was like,
wow,
that's interesting.
Hmm.
I mean noodle on that.
And then I think Costa Rica's kind of squarely in the middle and a lot of
respects.
Uh,
so stuff to ponder work on both.
And also it just struck me that given all the talk about stoicism and so on,
that I tend to be people over the head with a stoicism in a lot of respects.
I would view as a complete philosophical system that checks a lot of boxes but
does focus quite a bit on refining your expectations and preparing for the worst
case scenario.
So I often had quite a healthy dose of epicureanism and so on,
which is more on the opposite side and any case,
Tim,
thank you so much and we're going to jump into some audience questions.
[inaudible] definitely be doing
some individual Hellos,
but we jump in and see what we have here.
And a,
I suspect there might be some curve balls slash bear traps that I don't want to
step into.
So let me see what we have here.
Bear with.
All right.
Uh,
you're 20 you have three to six months pre job post college.
All right,
I take that to me in three to six months after graduation to do whatever and no
financial social commitments.
And you've already read Tim's books.
All right,
thank you for that.
How do you spend your time to maximize well being and developed perspective
Amman from Paris,
wellbeing and develop perspective three to six months.
Now you may have already done this,
where's month?
It's money here.
Hey,
how's it going on?
All right,
so you may have already done this,
but if,
if I were giving advice to
the
normal American audience for that,
I would say travel for those three to six months.
Go to countries where you do not speak the language,
get deliberately lost in places that are safe,
perhaps like Japan or Costa Rica and most places and for wellbeing and
developing perspective,
wellbeing would me and deliberately exposing yourself to people who are worse
off.
Maybe at least financially than yourself.
So spending part of that time volunteering for instance,
and this three to six months and then that will simultaneously help you to
develop many,
many different perspectives.
That would be just as speaking as someone who's life was changed completely by a
number of overseas experiences,
which I had starting at age 16 or 17 I'd never really spent time outside of the
u s that would be my recommendation.
Tim,
do you have any other,
any other thoughts?
No,
I think that's right in line with what I would have said,
which is
we basically traveling to me is like,
and that is another way to zoom out because you're just looking at your life
from far away.
You know?
It's like you don't,
you're not going there to look at your life,
but you ended up thinking about your life for some reason.
Being far away,
being out of your comfort zone and out of your element.
You just have fresh eyes on your whole situation.
You can have this perspective.
You can kind of,
it's like going in a helicopter and looking at it from up there and a lot of
things make sense.
And then I would have also said couple that with like kind of like,
um,
a hard zoom in on like reality,
which is,
which I think you get from,
um,
I might've said like wait tables were construction,
just do something where you kind of like you're just around working people.
Um,
and you're just,
um,
I dunno,
it just,
it just just reminds you what like work is like,
what reality is like,
what adults you know,
go through and then that can like help you figure out where you're about to,
you know,
where you're about to be in what you want to do.
Yeah,
for sure.
The travel advice,
I would not limit to someone just going to college.
I think everybody when possible,
it shouldn't have that experience because the benefits outlast the trip because
what'll happen to most people,
especially if you put yourself in very foreign environments where perhaps you
can't even read what is written in Japan,
China,
many different examples,
right?
Whether it's Cyrillic,
Arabic doesn't matter,
I and you observe different customs.
What happened to me,
at least in Japan for instance,
so my first real time abroad for a year as an exchange student,
the only
person who looks like this and a school uniform in a high school of 5,000
Japanese kids,
right?
Pretty easy where's Waldo game,
but I was like,
wait,
they drive on the other side of the street?
That doesn't make any sense.
Then I was like,
wait a second.
Maybe we don't make any sense
what they take a shower before they get into the bathtub.
That doesn't make any,
wait a second.
That makes perfect sense and I got back and I realized how many rules we follow
are just made up.
They're just totally made up.
Very fragile,
socially reinforced illusions that we just reinforced and that's very liberating
because you realize,
wait a minute,
like if all of these different cultures do things differently,
maybe I don't have to go there to do things differently.
I can do that here.
Then you start to really question assumptions and you become,
in my experience,
more experimental.
All right.
Let's go to
another question.
What trends,
industries,
topics are you most excited about right now?
Patrick?
Patrick,
is Patrick here?
Hey Bedrick all right.
I like that.
Hi.
Tim.
Applies to both of us.
Simplifies matters.
Uh,
what trends,
industries,
topics am I most excited about right now?
Uh,
speaking for myself,
trends.
I'm not watching very closely.
Uh,
like I have trouble explaining why really I suppose I'm not trying to capitalize
on any trends because I feel like particularly having left Silicon Valley and
having moved to Austin,
which I love on almost every level,
if I'm spotting trends that I hope to capitalize on,
by the time you see it,
you're too late,
generally speaking.
So I'm not paying a lot of attention to trends,
industries.
Uh,
I am interested just almost from an academic standpoint in space travel,
not so much from a personal experiential standpoint,
but specifically looking at inhabiting planets versus building space stations.
That debate is interesting to me because you have some of the smartest humans
last 5,000 years,
arguably with very,
very different viewpoints.
And whenever that happens in any field,
I'm really interested.
Uh,
you see that quite a few places,
topics I would say,
uh,
and this might be considered a trend.
I'm hoping to turn it into a trend which would be scientific research using
current cutting edge technologies to re-examine,
uh,
both psychedelics end Mtma,
which I wouldn't strictly consider the traditional sense of psychedelic for
applications to very debilitating,
serious conditions ranging from PTSD to resist treatment resistant depression,
end of life,
anxiety and so forth.
So I've taken most of my energy and capital that went into startups and
redirecting that to the scientific research at Johns Hopkins.
Hopefully other places like UCF,
Nyu also that are taking these compounds that have been used very,
very wisely,
I think in certain contexts for Millennia by various civilizations and uh,
applying a scientific lens to understand the mechanisms of action and the risks
involved quite frankly,
but how they can be less politicized and stigmatized for unscientific reasons
and examined so that we have a better understanding of why they do what they do,
which can be pretty incredible.
What about you,
trends,
industries,
topics that you're excited about right now?
Um,
definitely some of those,
uh,
agree with you on getting the stigma off of a prospective altering drugs.
But,
um,
I would,
uh,
I would also add,
um,
there's a lot of cool things going on and what the field but also has this
stigma called life extension and the stigma is that it just seems like it's
like,
you know,
narcissistic,
rich white guys and want to live forever.
But the truth is it's a,
and people think it's vain and narcissistic kind of thing,
but really what you could just reframe it as it's,
if you just cure or learn how to manage like the four things that kill people
basically,
which is like heart disease,
stroke,
Alzheimer's,
cancer.
Um,
it just means that like [inaudible] and other things going on in health,
like we can just live a lot longer and higher quality later years.
Like who doesn't want that?
It's this like knee jerk reaction that that makes people not even want to put
money your time into this industry.
But like I just feel like there were definitely people back when humans lived on
average to 40.
You know,
it would have been like,
oh,
did deck the 40 is the lot of man like living to 80 yourself.
But like now we're all happy about that.
No one wants to go back.
So if suddenly,
you know,
I dunno,
one 41 40 was the new 90 and 90 was the new 50.
Like,
who's not happy about that?
so,
uh,
you know,
we always say,
oh look,
cause you know,
at that point you're done.
We'll demo Lance's cause we got used to that.
We're managing our own expectations.
If we all died at 35,
I would be like,
well it's been good.
But like I'm not that I'm all ambitious and exciting because I think I have more
decades.
So,
um,
I think that,
uh,
there's a lot going on.
Mark Zuckerberg and his wife and our program,
you know,
one of the teams that are trying to cure all diseases by the end of the century.
Like this is just a machine and the diseases are just a glitch inside of the
machine.
Like,
if we can have,
you know,
enough nanotech and really fancy AI and um,
medicine,
you know,
and everything we can,
we can go in there and fix it.
This is a fantastic development.
The most heartbreaking thing is someone you know that you love dying especially
early.
Uh,
let's work on that.
So I think there's a lot going on there,
but I think that a lot more would be going on if the stigma of this as kind of
like a narcissistic pursuit would just go away.
Yeah.
To,
to come in on one thing there in terms of the,
the narcissistic rich people,
you,
everyone should want the narcissistic millionaires and billionaires to spend
much money as possible
on this,
right?
You want them to be the people who create the economies of scale for everybody
else.
And many of the things we take for granted now,
like recycling started off being very hoity toity affluence experiments and,
and you,
you want them to be spending millions of dollars on something then 10 years
going to be available for $50 a month.
Yes.
Plumbing,
like in sanitation,
these things are all rich,
rich people things for awhile.
And like then everyone benefits tremendously from them.
So like people also get mad.
They think,
oh and this is,
well this is just going to benefit like the rich.
It's this unfair thing where like super rich people will be able to live longer
and it's like,
yeah,
for a while.
And then it trickles to everybody cause the cost comes down as we get better.
So like get over it,
you know,
on that note,
yeah.
Uh,
if you want to read some,
I think very interesting thinking related to what might account to life
extension or at least death prevention.
Doctor Peter a tia is willing to pay attention to one of my favorite people.
Uh,
Eh,
what is the name of the city everyone must visit before they die?
Thanks for everything.
Steve.
Steve Grill.
Not to be confused with Steve Carell.
This ca.
Yeah,
it was a great name.
It's a great name.
Spelled differently.
Uh,
I on my list,
I would have to go with Tokyo because it has such an unusual combination of
safety,
cleanliness,
extreme weirdness and incomprehensibility even to someone who speaks to and haze
that it provides a really unite,
a unique,
I think I just used that twice and I'm going to get shipped from friends who
love to heckle me for using modifiers on unique.
They're like,
no,
there's no such thing as very unique like,
okay,
alright,
alright.
I'm going to say it again.
Just annoy them.
It's a very unique opportunity to feel extreme discomfort and confusion with
elation with next to no real harmful consequences.
So I think that provides an awesome learning opportunity and just a fun trip.
So I would say,
I would say Tokyo is very high on the list.
Right?
You still my answer again,
I was just in Japan all summer and the sun,
it's like going to another planet and you're like,
oh,
how did,
how did this civilization live?
And you're on another planet.
That's how different it is.
And just isolated western culture has like,
you know,
infiltrated so many places and it just hasn't really there and they just have
done everything their own way.
And so you're like,
how does the cab door open?
Oh,
it opens by itself.
Then I get in and it closes by itself.
That's really cool.
So I had to give a different answer.
I'll say,
um,
Hanoi,
Vietnam,
just because crossing the street is just crazy.
So there's like
bites just like motorbikes,
just a sea of a sea of them going by and there's no stop lights and it doesn't
stop.
And what you do is it walkers,
you just walk.
It's like,
it's like Indiana Jones,
like walking over the thing.
Um,
you,
you just walk and you just,
and they figure it out and,
and it's unbelievable.
It's like you feel like you're like God walking on water or something.
Were you just like,
you're just like walk out and nothing happens,
but the thing you don't want to do is like,
we have freaked out towards that like stops cause then,
then the,
then you're doing it.
It's something they can't anticipate,
but you got to try this time.
Steady.
Well based strides.
Competent,
yes.
Yeah.
All right.
Is it the same there?
I didn't go down there.
He spent some time in coaching then
I was actually trying.
Yeah,
go with the flow or else you die.
Good,
good advice.
Thank goodness.
All right.
That one would take us both several hours knowing the two of us.
I apologize to the person whose name I will not read.
Uh,
alright dear Tim,
that applies both of us regarding two crappy pages per day.
I'll explain what that means.
How do you structure your days and weeks when you are working on a book?
Thanks Jean or Jeannie.
I'm not sure if the,
all right,
I'll,
I'll go with [inaudible] both.
I wasn't sure how to respond.
All right,
so the two crappy pages per day for those who don't know was advice that I
received,
I received regarding writing and working on a book,
which you can be in my personal experience,
a very daunting,
intimidating task and I would get frozen for days or weeks and I'd try to write
something.
It wouldn't be perfect and I'd throw it out.
And at a mentor of mine or an author I knew said your quota should be two crappy
pages per day.
And he told me the story about IBM and how they demolish the competition by
exceeding every sales quota every quarter and just absolutely steamrolling
everyone for a long time.
And he asked me,
do you know why that is?
And I said No.
And he said,
because of the quotas were low and then people were unintimidated to pick up the
phone to make the calls.
Uh,
and you can do the same thing with yourself with writing.
And you do that by making your bar for a successful day,
two crappy pages.
That's it.
Even if you throw them both out,
you never use them.
You've won the day if you have to copy pages.
And of course over time there are days when you just get your two crappy pages
and they are really truly terrible.
And then there are other days where you overshoot,
you're in the flow and you get 10 1520 pages.
You don't need so many of those to eventually put together what can become a
button in terms of structuring my days and so on.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll be super,
super specific here because the weeks and months basically look identical and
it's just copy and paste of this particular day.
I realized for myself that I benefit greatly given historical predisposition to
bipolar and all of these various things.
It's just written in my code.
Uh,
it's a whole separate story.
But yeah,
it's kind of laughable.
And how it predisposed my family has that writing your sunshine is really
important.
So I write books generally during summer months and my day involves getting up
not super early,
but for me it was respect respectably early,
which would mean say 9:00 AM nine 30 before the sun is setting and I wake up,
I meditate for 20 to 22 minutes.
It should be typically transcendental meditation or some type of guided
meditation.
Then I jumped in the water because I'm on Lake Long Island and jump in the water
to wake up.
I might do a little bit of swimming.
I hop out.
I already have pages from the night before that I want to edit.
I will edit during the day,
but I,
I do my pros generation at night.
That's just when I have the best output.
But I can edit,
do that grunt work during the day.
I have printed out pages.
I will go into a sauna,
which requires all sorts of trickery because you start sweating on the pages,
but go into a sauna and I will hand edit those pages.
Then I come out,
take a quick shower.
I have a very small breakfast of some time,
typically say macadamia nuts,
some eggs.
Very,
very small and I continue to work very often at a treadmill desk and the
treadmill desk works during this period of time at a very slow pace because say
in the case of tribe of mentors,
I'm handling outreach and editing.
I'm not going to do comp it original drafts and composition at the treadmill
desk.
Uh,
I will work at the treadmill desk.
This is literally the exact day and this one would take hours to explain it.
Then around say noon or 1:00 PM hop on a bike with a researcher or someone that
I have hired to be with me in the same house at all times.
Why is this important?
I realized that writing is very isolating for me and it,
it can catalyze a lot of negative mental states and downward spirals because I
feel alone so I have someone physically there even though we could probably do
the work remotely,
they have to be optimistic,
which fortunately my researcher is everything to him.
His hand clapping.
Amazing.
Really good influence have around.
So we both get on a bike,
so you'll notice there are there,
there's,
there are little bursts of physical exercise inserted in the day,
get on bikes,
ride to this very mediocre Deli and we have Mediterranean raps every day
for those interested it is whole wheat tortilla with chicken,
hummus,
tomato,
Avocado added,
always extra cost
and we eat our Mediterranean wraps and I have unsweetened ice tea plus sparkling
water and we work there until say five or six sun starts to set,
jump on the bikes,
sometimes head to the bay,
jump in the water again,
head home,
uh,
and then have a snack,
work for an additional two or three hours,
then go to dinner.
There are two or three restaurants that we go to.
That's it.
Those are the rotations.
And for all of these restaurants will give a pro tip.
Jesus with a long answer that I said wasn't getting along.
All right,
pro tip for people who might want to do this.
Now it's late.
We're going out late,
rubbing dinner at nine o'clock.
A lot of these kitchens closed and say nine 30 10,
what does that mean?
Staff's going to be fucking pissed.
They were coming in right as the doors about to close.
And I know this because I worked in service jobs as busboys and waiter in
restaurants forever.
I get it.
So here's what you do.
You have three restaurants,
you know you're going to be going to them for a few weeks or few months.
You go to the same restaurant for dinner three nights in a row,
and then the next restaurant,
same place,
three nights in a row,
each night you buy rounds of Tequila over and over again.
For every person who works in the restaurant,
front of House and back of house,
really important.
These people will now love you and they will let you hang out for an extra hour,
hour and a half.
This is really key.
Uh,
okay.
So we do this,
then we go home,
not too much to Cuba and uh,
will continue to prepare things for the next day.
Go to bed around 1:00 AM say,
and then it's groundhog day over and over again.
That's it.
And there are very often,
I would say every other day,
some type of a kettlebell swings or exercise that has done immediately before
leaving to dinner.
And it's just that day over and over and over again.
Yes.
I see your raised hands from yes,
Joanne.
Yeah.
Genie.
Goddammit.
Sorry,
when you were having the Mediterranean racks.
Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
So important to clarify and question.
Do I work where we have lunch?
Yes.
Their outdoor picnic tables and we will sit down and work outside.
That's actually a fairly key point,
but you have to have a high tolerance for mosquitoes and ticks because it's
eastern long island.
So caveat emptor on the Lyme disease or uh,
Tim,
um,
if you take the opposite of that answer,
I think there's 16 hours a week is like a,
a morphous Wad and self loving.
It's basically someone asks me that would be like,
what do you,
what do you need with your work?
What do you do?
And I was like,
I need to know that will follow me around and like shock me if I'm not working
and like,
wait,
I'm supposed to be working.
And they were kind of like,
that was kind of,
but,
um,
I,
uh,
yeah,
no,
no.
I mean,
I mean this is what you're awesome at and what I admire you for an eye.
You can also,
just to be clear,
have really regimented,
well-structured self-loathing just to make that clear.
Continue.
But I was like trying to memorize it,
that answer because I want to like,
I think for me,
the times when I am being productive,
um,
I find that it,
the two days of the two minutes,
a two pages a day thing resonates with me because for me it's like if I get in
my by,
by problem when I'm not being productive is that I had this in my head.
I'm behind on my stuff.
So I need to work 14 hours.
I need 14 hours of writing today.
Um,
and I have done those crazy hours when there like a crazy panic in my life.
So I,
I know I can.
So I think I can,
but without the panic it never happens.
And then six hours into the day,
I've already blown it.
I've already blown the day.
And you get discouraged and then you start to self fulfilling prophecy yourself.
That of course I'm going to blow it.
I blew the last three days and then so if I do the same thing,
I say I'm going to write three hours today and then I've had a successful day.
It's amazing.
All the positive like reward pathway feedback that comes in from feeling like
you succeeded that day.
Um,
and then that night you can go to bed on time because I already succeeded today
as opposed to thinking,
no,
I can't go to bed now.
I can't like let this be the the whole day I didn't and that can feed on itself.
And something I try to remind myself is someone who is three,
three hours of writing,
five days a week but really focused like phone is away like deep,
deep focus writing 15 hours a week.
Like it's shocking how much you can produce.
Like add those weeks together.
40 weeks later you have a book,
right?
The difference between the prolific writer and the person does self-loathing
person who doesn't write anything is one does 15 hours a week out of their
hundred and 12 Weking hours a week writing and the other one does zero to 112
waking hours.
So one seven versus zero sevens six seven.
So those two people's days and lines are the same.
I mean,
it is.
So people go,
people who can put something together,
they have this daunting kind of assumption that the prolific writers
fundamentally different.
They're just,
they just had,
they're working constantly all the time.
Um,
it doesn't have to be that way,
but it's the consistency.
It is the IBM thing.
I have never thought about it that way.
That's a really great way to put it.
So true too.
I mean,
most,
most writers I know spend the majority of their time inventing things to,
to avoid writing.
But my,
my plants dying.
There's,
there's really no way that I could possibly,
Winston needs another massage.
Yeah,
I am.
And this is an unconstructive environment.
The writing's not going to be high quality if I don't Polish my tennis shoes.
And so on a very,
very pure,
I,
this will be the last question and then we'll move on to the next phase of this
evening.
Uh,
what experiments,
questions,
hypotheses are you wrestling with right now?
How have they changed over your life?
Where do you think they'll take you?
Now?
We may not have a chance to hit every aspect of this,
but let's,
let's start with what experiments,
questions,
hypotheses.
It's,
let's start with you telling shit.
So nice having his answer.
What experiments,
questions or hypotheses are you wrestling with right now?
And then let's,
I'm just going to approach this and go do,
where do you think they might take you?
Well,
it's a little like my last answer.
I am trying to,
so my mind is structured,
uh,
as I explained in the Ted talk,
you mentioned,
um,
with,
there's the,
there's three characters,
there's the rational decision maker who's like,
she would help me work right now it's 10:00 AM it's,
you know,
on a Wednesday,
a very good time to work.
Then there's the,
the,
his pets,
the instinct gratification monkey who uh,
he does not,
he has a different idea,
is a different idea of what 10:00 AM on Wednesday is good for.
And then there's a,
and the two of them go back and forth and the instant gratification monkey wins
every single time,
which leaves me and what I call the dark playground where I'm like not working
but I'm supposed to be.
Um,
and the only thing,
the only thing that breaks that cycle is the third character who suddenly wakes
up when a deadline gets closer or there's some external pressure that's the
panic monster and the panic monster freaks the monkey out.
The only thing the monkey scared of,
he runs away and I can get my thing done and I'm going to die at 45.
Um,
and what I'm trying to learn how to do,
especially since I'm about to start my first book next year,
so I like,
you've done 52 books.
I need to like learn from.
This man is like,
you know,
a book is too big a project.
You can't just do that all at once.
I,
it's like,
it's like at some point you have to learn how to have this internal,
uh,
motivation.
And for me,
I'm like,
uh,
you know,
a caricature of myself,
but there's a lot of people in this room who maybe aren't classic
procrastinators,
but,
uh,
without realizing it,
if there's no kind of deadline,
even if they're not down to the wire with the deadline,
the deadline itself,
just being there is what makes them do stuff.
And that's dangerous.
Um,
because actually a lot of what's really important in life is that kind of
important but not urgent stuff.
The stuff that doesn't have the deadlines,
seeing your friends and family and not fuck changing careers,
improving yourself in the long run.
So I think like this whole,
these three characters thing applies to a lot of people,
applies very much to me.
So I'm working on is trying to,
just really,
really working on,
uh,
having productive days,
with nothing in the external world,
making me because a child is not good at that.
And I,
I trying to be,
uh,
less of a child.
That's my goal for the next year.
Yeah.
I empathize.
I do.
I do,
uh,
most productive person in the history of,
no,
I'm just really good at showing like the high,
right,
the high,
right.
Well,
I got really super,
when I get tired this is going to give me an all sorts of trouble.
I actually,
after spending a year only speaking Japanese,
when I get really tired,
I start to mix up my in my house.
I'm not shitting you.
Wow.
You speak Japanese.
Yeah.
That's so cool.
Yeah,
it's a cool language.
Uh,
so,
and just so you guys know,
I'm just going to digress for a second.
In Japanese,
they have naughty duty though they have a syllabus and the our l and d sounds
are kind of combined into one thing.
That's why they're not aware of the distinction.
They kinda got screwed when God was handing out phonemes that didn't get a lot
of sounds.
It's really hard for them to learn other languages,
but of a rip off for them.
But,
uh,
I'm showing the highlight reel of like a very mediocre movie.
So I'm getting,
it creates the illusion that I'm just knocking out productivity all day,
not the case.
Which is why when people are like,
can we follow you around for a day?
I'm like,
no,
absolutely not.
Naturally not because you'd just be like,
are you going to do something
though man?
I'm like,
I found some lint in the carpet and I need to fix this.
Not a good like dances with wolves experience for the documentary film goer.
Uh,
all right,
so what experience questions,
hypotheses in my wrestling with right now,
I'm going to make this maybe a little soft around the edges,
which is not my style tip events like hard analytical,
quantitative,
uh,
but whatever.
Uh,
so I've spent the vast majority of my life at best tolerating myself.
It's true.
Uh,
had had some,
some really horrible experiences early on that led me to just decide sort of
self love is for other people.
I could be a really good instrument for competition though.
I get home myself into an instrument with a high pain tolerance to be really
good at certain things.
And that was enough.
And then I could get my joy or happiness where I found that from observing other
people,
long storytelling packed that fully.
But suffice to say like I accepted a really low level of self regard and it was
really,
really unforgiving.
The brutal with myself.
I mean I,
I talked to myself endlessly everyday we're talking about decades in a way that
I would never speak to another person.
And what I've realized in the last few months actually in particular is that if
you want to fully love other people and to make other people feel loved,
you can't get away with just tolerating yourself.
You cannot and you have to learn how to
forgive yourself for a lot.
Uh,
but more so than that for me at least is to have compassion for earlier versions
of yourself that you might view as cowardly or ashamed or week.
And uh,
I was introduced to that through something relatively new for me,
which is called Meta m e t t a or loving kindness meditation,
which sounds Super Woo.
And I mean the 20 year old version of Tim would just be vomiting on his shoes
right now.
Hearing this like,
Oh my God,
you're embarrassing us.
Stop it.
But it's been a really profound shift in my perspective and realizing that even
if my only goal is not necessarily to love myself but to do the greatest good I
can possibly do with my small amount of time on this planet,
that I have to put my on oxygen mask on first.
And that's something that comes up a lot and try to mentors Arianna Huffington,
Sharon Salzberg,
it comes up again and again and I just want everybody to realize this is part of
my,
I suppose,
new mission of sorts is for people to realize that if you're feeling damaged or
flawed and that leads you to be depressed and to have really,
really low amount of regard for yourself where you're really aggressively brutal
to yourself,
that the first thing to realize is that you are not alone in feeling that.
And in fact,
I certainly not everyone in this book,
but I would wager,
and this is just speculation in most cases,
but a very,
very high percentage
have incredible demons and are fighting battles that we all know nothing about.
But I mean really with some very,
very dark periods.
So a,
is that you're not alone and B is that you can actually
let go of and repair almost all,
if not all of what you think you should just lock away and forget.
So that I suppose would be what I am wrestling with right now and working on and
try to communicate and there's some really concrete ways you can go about it.
I would recommend everybody,
certainly,
if any of that resonates,
do yourself a favor,
get a book called radical acceptance by Tara Brock.
Terrible title,
fantastic book.
Give it a read.
I could have a huge impact.
Yeah,
that's a good question about psychedelics.
I would say,
uh,
that yes is my tentative answer,
but I would not recommend that anyone tage psychedelics without professional
supervision.
There are legal ramifications to consider and I would take it as seriously as
you would choosing a neurosurgeon to remove a tumor that if miss operated on
were resulted in a fatality.
It's a lot of people right now.
Sorry man.
That's about it right now.
A lot of people are going on craigslist and finding neurosurgeons.
My friend's a shaman would just order some stuff from the Internet,
from China for Iowasca.
We're going to do it in our slow cooker.
That idea that,
that,
that idea.
Uh,
so there are many tools.
I don't think that's the only tool.
Meditation,
Silent Retreats,
which I'm not ready to do,
recommend it cause I do think they can be extremely destabilizing.
There are many,
many tools in the toolkit,
but the point I want to make is there are tools and you can start with something
that does not involve visiting your ancestors and seeing flashing neon
crocodiles in your mind,
which could be radical acceptance is to take a look.
Thank you guys very much and thank Tim.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by convert kit,
my goto email service provider,
I use them for everything.
If you've ever wondered how professional bloggers,
podcasters,
youtubers,
and so on can build a platform they control and get the word out about their
best content.
Email is still the answer.
People think it's all social,
social,
but one algorithm change.
Oops,
bait and switch.
Now you only reach 10% of your audience.
That is why I've doubled and tripled down on an end mill.
After reviewing many different email service providers,
I ended up selecting convert kit for email like five bullet Friday,
which goes out to about a million people now because convert kit delivers on
what matters most to me at least easy to use.
Systems,
split testing and resending technology,
both very,
very important.
High rates of deliverability and great hands on customer service.
So whether you run a business or simply have,
say a serious blog convert kit has integrations with more than 70 different
services just about anything you might need,
including hosting sites like wordpress,
ecommerce platform like Shopify,
lead capture technology like bounce exchange or sumo and many more.
They also offer a visual automation builder that makes it really easy to deliver
the right content to the right people in your audience just when they want it.
If you want to segment in different ways,
which a lot of people do,
convert kit offers,
plants that adjusted the size of your business,
so it's good option whether you have a thousand people or 1 million on your
list,
and certainly I am planning on growing and growing and growing and I don't like
switching email service providers,
so I thought very carefully about this before I selected them to check it out.
Take a look@convertkit.com forward slash 10 that's convert Con v e r t k,
I t.com/tim and you can get your first month for free.
Kick the tires,
test it out.
That way you can give it a shot.
Make sure that it works for you,
your business and all of that goodness.
If you're like me,
I hope you'll find that they get the job done.
That's certainly been my experience.
It's check it out.
Again,
that's convert kit.com forward slash Tim for a free month of email services.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike and the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude,
you look great,
what the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasted like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You know if worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to a
studio,
it's some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find her own favorite class on demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do live
classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like not Wilbur's and his eye high intensity training sessions that are
shorter of 20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to
have their favorite instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that along with the real time leaderboard are the main reasons that this
caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect,
so it can fit in a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not,
and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys the snares of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer,
and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o,
n e p e l o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say Matt accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes.
And those are in the accessory category.
So this $100 off is a very legit,
$100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else,
or are you just want to get a fantastic gift for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories,
including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code.
Tim.